welcome to podcast Ville the Church of
what's happened now is brought to you by
my bookie that's right it's that season
again you dirty [ __ ] you've been
sitting there [ __ ] grinding at the
teeth building your bankroll ready to
[ __ ] rock but you're like what am I
gonna spend it on do I start preseason
[ __ ] yeah you start preseason why
because my bookies here that they care
you remember it's not what you're
betting it's as important is who you're
betting with that's why I always tell
people to bet with my bookie why I only
recommend the service to my listeners
and to the church family that's been
good to me that's why I'm urging you to
make your way to my bookie you win they
pay that's what it's all about right or
wrong so join my bookie and we'll match
your deposit dollar-for-dollar use promo
code Church CH you are CH to activate
the offer right now you play you win you
get [ __ ] paid visit my bookie online
that's my bookie my Bo okay ie if you
didn't watch Sesame Street growing up
and don't forget to use promo Church
when you create your club account to
claim up to a thousand and free play
number two you're gonna go to judge it
sooo it's four months from the holidays
you're a fat [ __ ] you didn't give a [ __ ]
about the [ __ ] summer summer but now
you're like Jesus I gotta do some of my
body
you're gonna go to Fuji sports.com like
us is the best gear you [ __ ] get in
the business whether it's a super ato
the cycle point to the elemental listen
I'm a fat [ __ ] they put they told they
pull my sleeves nothing I go home to
[ __ ] Giza tip-top Magoo nobody's
ripping you can't hang yourself with
that you can even hang yourself with one
of these [ __ ] sleeves I thought up
these [ __ ] gears so go to Fuji Sports
calm right now press ENTER CH and get
10% off anything a shin guard a
mouthpiece how about the church cut it
out [ __ ] go to Fuji sports.com
pressing church and get your party
started kick this [ __ ] melee
[ __ ] true man damn man I would kill
to be able to sing like that you know
what I mean
God like I said as actors comics we all
have like a secret thing and that's what
I want to be a museum but I was wrong
coke I'm a musician I would have sold
the guitar every two weeks I will have
to buy a new ukulele I won't have to
show up with a gig with a banjo
one week was the guitar to him I gotta
believe I got a rock can get robbed the
appointed for a grand [ __ ] Sean
Kerrigan
what's a pleasure to have you on the
parquet man it's an honor to be on your
father
it's great to have you on you uh you did
something for me that I never told you
i'ma tell you today what you did for me
yeah changed the game for me what calm
okay so I booked this movie named grudge
match with a director who had worked
with before and the narrow [ __ ]
Stallone and LL Cool J and this guy John
Byrne uh it was just a great cast lady
Kim Basinger and I've got flown down to
New Orleans and I go in there a day
early and I go are they shooting today
and they go yeah they're shooting at my
go over and I watched the LL Cool J
scenes with DeNiro and it's a big hug at
first they're using lapin hands and they
do a couple rehearsals and everything is
beautiful I'm sitting there for now so
you're just on the outside you just
sitting there no one's talking here not
a word nobody's even saying boo to me
nobody's talking to me and I watch that
to take start to happen and hello Cool J
goes into a scene and he's [ __ ] cut
and then there's another scene let's do
it again and LL Cool J and cut and I go
what the [ __ ] is wrong go Jay you know
well it the same thing happen so I had a
shoot of scene the next day one time he
seen like I was like scene number five
and the shooting started at 8:00 so I
went down there by 12 8 mm-hmm and sat
around there Watts I didn't say a word
nobody talked to me and up to the part
they were setting up for that scene and
I'm [ __ ] bagels ya know warm up
would [ __ ] an extra no warm up or any
money no warm up with nobody I really
rather warmed up with anybody but
[ __ ] they throw you into the cage
yeah that's it man ambassador yeah still
anybody but no yeah no one was like hey
yes I'll talk to you auto buyer so
dinero comes over on his own and he goes
you whatever
my characters lay in my way yeah I get
up and I shake his hand he doesn't very
nice to meet you do you want to rehearse
a couple times I go sure absolutely you
don't goes let me just take care of this
and I'll come back and in that [ __ ]
minute I sit down on the mic I got in my
five minutes I could get up walk the
[ __ ] that's it everything comes to your
mind negative like the reasons why
you're not supposed to be here
they miscast you that they're looking
for a black guy this is just wrong you
know and all this are they gonna tap on
the show no it's your buddy Chuck Jon
Bernthal and he goes how you doing John
because I'm friends with Sean Kerrigan
and he said that you're the real deal
like on stage you're the real [ __ ]
deal to the depth of the table and you
know what ma'am he was like an angel
like I looked at him and I knew I didn't
know who the [ __ ] he was I just knew
that I had seen him before
yeah and you know for him just to say
that dude is a stand-up dude it gave me
what the narrow came back mm-hmm it gave
me a little [ __ ] home swipe yeah
okay that I could deal with this I still
[ __ ] up because I once that scene
happened I realized what was happening -
how cool J yeah they say action good you
see taxi driver you see I mean the first
is sakes God you just see all these
movies he did and you just like your
whole body freedom feeling I'm not gonna
do a scene with the priest when you play
the priest with [ __ ] Sean Penn with
one of the worst movies of all time man
was it horrible but he still did you
know he still had so what you did for me
I remember coming back and bumping into
you in the haha
you know but I never told you that that
was well a man you know the dude Joey it
it's cuz it's true man you know I didn't
say anything that wasn't true
you know John John when I remember when
when he called me he was a gay man he's
like there's a there's a comedian you
know commit John's always I checking up
on people he's like you know
like just figure out someone's like for
real or whatever you know and I mean
just like an if they're cool and in he
goes it called me a man this guy Joey
Diaz he's it's chameleon you know I was
like hell yeah I know I'm dude I said
that - it's the I just bragged about you
guys he's hilarious he's hilarious he's
a great dude like you were cuz you were
always really cool whenever I saw you
you know and so I just said I was like
yeah man I guess the best man and he
came right over
yeah actually I spent the whole day with
him into there oh just sitting on a
bench well you know how that goes on
yeah I got this [ __ ] guy behind me
yeah and I got De Niro I know how Cool J
in front of me this can't be real
like this is like a [ __ ] joke mm-hmm
what was more nerve-racking for you that
or stand-up comedy in front of thousands
or like what's what's scarier stand-up
comedy still scares me when I go up in
front of a people or whether I going
from 300 never Church people
I still get petrified the fear with De
Niro and doing a scene with somebody out
of your realm like I did a scene with
James Cobra what was that like man just
what do you think it's gonna be like
yeah but I wasn't as nervous right as I
was virgin they're De Niro [ __ ] yeah
yeah man James Coburn [ __ ] me up on
the first tank again but I didn't know
what had [ __ ] me up and I did the take
with De Niro I knew what had [ __ ] me
out was just too many visuals I still
keep fear they think De Niro did popped
up and I just froze and then he came
over and and let me tell you man
I saw the movie the you know I'm upset
that that movie didn't do better than it
than it did you know I it's almost it's
weird it's like I don't know what they'd
like promoted it right or marketed it
right
you know but cuz I thought that movie
was fantastic like is that is it was
great man
you were you were funny man I was lucky
no but what [ __ ] up about a movie like
that is you expected the expectations
but here's the I on vacation but I keep
forgetting the raging bulls a great
movie
it's an Academy Award winner but I don't
know if you got the memo it was 33 years
ago Rocky Academy award-winner [ __ ]
one of the greatest stories of all time
I know man I go that is 24 and 17 that's
34 and 7 that's 41 [ __ ] years ago
you know this year it's at this this
last month was the anniversary of Enter
the Dragon yeah 45 years ago Lee people
of an atom blame the youth it's not
their fault yeah but see that's the
thing man they should have advertised it
like that
they should have advertised it like look
at these like fossils like you're gonna
like yeah I mean they're gonna go at it
and you know I mean they should
advertise it like but you cuz I thought
I thought it was funny I thought it was
funny if you see you're an actor you're
anything you've been when you were a kid
did you want to be an actor yeah really
yeah man I felt it's an early age for a
very early age man would you grow up I
grew up I grew up in Miami Florida and
but grammar school yeah yeah all the way
up all the way up through high school
was that it was it was weird man because
I lived down there with my mom and and
and I was little I like I hit puberty
real late what was that if you don't
mind me uh he was up in DC knowing that
Virginia I got like I got like a really
uh I got a kind of a dysfunctional
family man yeah I did but they're but
they're cool man and they're all cool
mom Irish awesome yeah yeah yeah I was
Catholic yeah man so I was living down
in Miami and uh and you know it was I
was little and so I just said you know
when I was when I was a teenager just
said hey man you know I think I'm gonna
just gonna start wrestling and boxing
and so I I started wrestling cotton in
high school and then uh I started I
started a box and I would go up and my
dad was an ex pro boxer and so he would
train fighters and stuff so when I
I spent my summers up there I was always
around boxing gyms and everything and
it's how it was always like you know
wanted to to to box and then I just
started competing at both of them and
then yeah and then uh and then uh you
know I did pretty well went to state
champs and then and then and then I went
in I wrestled in college and uh arrested
at George Mason University and and then
I had I had I had a bunch more amateur
fights too I was I was boxing and
wrestling the same time and so it's it's
it's weird man it's weird to talk about
all this stuff cuz you know a lot of
this stuff that I did you know
athletically in wrestling and boxing
like I never I never achieved my
potential I think and I don't know if
like if if if that's overthinking you
know being involved in a sport and
everything but I think every athlete you
know unless they're like a champion must
always feel like they left a little
something on the table and and let me
ask you this yeah you
you fought Pro for one year two years to
you two what did you think I thought uh
I thought that you know the thing about
fighting in the pros is you know
especially boxing it's about having
having a good amateur career so that you
can have a good manager that'll get you
the right fights and that's how but all
boxing starts out and so you're fighting
like a lot of guys in the pros that you
know aren't really up to your speed but
they kind of bring you along you know I
mean you fight guys are a little bit
better a little bit better and then and
then you start getting tested and then
they start bringing in a you know
tougher guys and then and then and then
you climb the ranks that way and if you
if you if you handle when you get tested
you know and bye-bye guys it's really
good you know you're gonna have a career
but it's a very small percentage of
people that make the big bucks that
become the De La Hoya's the the
Mayweather's the Bernard Hopkins I mean
it's it's a very small percentage man
and I knew that I was never gonna be one
of those guys you know and I just when
did you find that
when you found out at what level at what
you know I thought I fought in the
National Championships a couple times
and in the amateurs and there was a guy
there was a guy named davon King and
another guy named Stephen Cunningham and
Stephen Cunningham ended up being a IBF
cruiserweight champion of the world he
was he was probably him and davon king
these two guys man davon King won the
Junior Worlds these two guys were the
two toughest guys I ever fought and I'd
say Steven Cunningham was the the
toughest cuz he dropped me in the second
and I got up and I finished I finished
the fight he's the only guy to ever drop
me in the amateurs only guy and uh and
so he I got out of that fight my dad
would always be real hard on me because
my dad was my trainer and so he'd always
be real hard on me he'd say hey you
should have won that fight you know why
hell didn't you you didn't do that you
didn't do the things within and and
usually I could understand where he was
coming from but when and when I fought
Steven Cunningham and he my dad started
lighting into me I was like hey hey hey
pop that that that dude that dudes gonna
be a world champion they're like I'm
there's nothing like I knew I knew at
that moment I was like there's nothing I
can do to beat that son of a [ __ ] man
he is he was that tough and and he did
he he ended up becoming IBF
cruiserweight champion just like I just
like I predicted no when you walked away
from boxing I will need the press corps
I was very torn because my dad told me
I'd be driving a cab for the rest of my
life because you know my dad was
training me and you know we had built I
was eight know as a pro you know and
really fought that many that many tough
guys but but he was he was like you know
so I was starting to build a little bit
of a following in the DC area you know I
get you know start putting butts in
seats and uh and then I came and told my
dad I was like alright well I'm good
I'm gonna I'm gonna call it quits while
I'm ahead
you know I'm leaving I'm walking away
with house money and so
and he just he said you know I told him
I was gonna go be an actor and he told
me I'd be driving a cab the rest of my
life so you talk to him today oh yeah I
mean so well then so then fast forward a
couple years later you know we were at a
screening and and he were supposed
sitting there getting ready to watch his
movie I'm in and he's sitting there it
was actually the movie I did with John
and so we're sitting in this screening
it was called Mary Mary and so we're
sitting in the screening and right
before the credit it's right before the
movie starts I turn over and I return to
my dad I go I go hey I thought you'd be
dead and gone before you sell me on the
screen
he's like you son of a [ __ ] you always
have to remember everything don't you so
if he had told me that he was like I'll
be dead and gone before and whatever
this is how man this ain't funny man you
know we're talking about comedy before
yeah I told you how I got addicted to it
now I had grown up working out and
lifting weights and all of a sudden
comedy had just taken over my life I
knew that it was the only thing I had
there was no other hope there was no
other hope for me Here I am living on
Josh Wolf's couch with you know eating
$0.49 cheeseburgers from Chili's a man
on the feeling that is what was it
called Chili's know what's the place to
that Wendy's Wendy's Wendy's had the
foil incense chili Kappa chili right I
go hey between the chili and the salad
she'll break yeah man I'll eat that
horse meat yeah I'll get that horse meat
with the crackers and I get 229 said
yeah whopper jr. hey so alive and yeah
that was the struggle and that was part
of the [ __ ] struggle but I will tell
you one thing I got left back in the
seventh grade and it devastated me just
devastated me because I knew I was
smarter than that I got left back
because I fell in love over a piece of
[ __ ] fell in love just stopped
everything it stopped my work the smell
of a girl's are joining to stop my world
[ __ ] homework [ __ ] karate [ __ ] my mother
[ __ ] my step for man [ __ ] Santeria [ __ ]
[ __ ] the church I'm in love man I'm
gonna marry this [ __ ] girl I'm gonna
run off with her and I got left back I
fell geography I felt like the [ __ ]
classes and I haven't go to summer
school and guess what I [ __ ] failed
summer school because I couldn't get my
mind off a dry humping it and I wasn't
even [ __ ] that's the sad thing Shona
that's how much of a [ __ ] [ __ ] I was
I wasn't even banging this chick I was
just driving up there which I loved
we were gonna run off to a Bon Jovi song
but Joey wasn't even around my Jovi was
still finger banging that write song
somewhere and I it was such a
devastation the [ __ ] left back that I
had to get something I already had the
karate and I was good at karate I
haven't gonna taunt him and so I can
always get a second or first place in
form I would get this qualify for
kicking a guy in the face a mother you
know yeah I just get carried away by bam
it could be sitting there Jesus Christ
you know but something made me get into
basketball
I mean something how old I was maybe 12
[ __ ] and I [ __ ] I've always loved
basketball and I just got into it the
guy became my everything it was part of
machine if I wasn't doing homework
I started getting A's because I didn't
tell my mother I got left back so I
couldn't have my mother go to the school
or even suspect holy [ __ ] so I had to
make for you forge report card yeah I
would I would have to supply this for
parent-teacher meetings and I just
[ __ ] it was horrible it was horrible
was the biggest lie I ever [ __ ] put
together in my life and but basketball
was everything yeah I would write
coaches I would write the University of
North Carolina and the ACC team I like I
wrote the head coach and [ __ ] got
their work out and I didn't I lifted
weights I did and I played against the
best competition in Hudson County now
and I was supposed to start freshman
year you know like it was if you looked
at all the grammar schools and
everything I was the forward and there
was another guy and it was a center and
there were two guards and I got to my
freshman year and
like this coach just did hahahaha man
and it just [ __ ] yeah not in the
practice huh I'd score like 90 in
practice like I would destroy the first
team in practice rainbow my life coach
flames he just did not like me we feel
people talk to him they threatened to
move me up if he didn't play me he was
like you ain't moving him up and you
know what man I got the drugs and I I
pushed it off I played from time to time
sophomore year I can go out man I never
play it again and it destroyed me till
this day I made up for it with the
comedy yeah but I wouldn't have lasted
long knowing that I gave up I gave up at
the age of 16 but yeah I'm not gonna
what Cuban is over six feet you know I
was just being honest with myself
give me a Cuban that's over six feet
beside Canseco Steven Bauer with 6-1 up
you know saying I mean the Cubans are
[ __ ] yeah but although you know I just
gave myself a bunch of excuses just as a
cop-out but till today I still talk to
all those kids they'll tell you sure dog
when you used to rock used to rock I
lived with that doubt today like now
today I'm like that bass but it made me
not quit comedy yeah well thank God man
and look you know my little brother my
little brother was wrestling cotton in
high school and he was just he was just
a he was just a [ __ ] out man he was he
was just he's in trouble and everything
and he had the same thing with his
wrestling coach his wrestling coaches
and he was he was incredible he was yeah
the most single season wins as a
freshman as a freshman in the in the
whole school so it for a freshman to
have the most single season wins was
just you know he was it wasn't very
impressive and he just he got he got
right before the why I haven't farted
for a while I shouldn't know oh man did
you a little woman had some Scouts I
know it was a blame on the coconut was
this hey anyways that was it man my
brother just got messed up
man that's it I wasn't growing up in
Miami the nightmare for you now you know
man I loved it man
I loved it you know I'll find these
people now now I get the even like even
more because I was the only white I was
the only kid on my wrestling team is all
it's all Cuban man Cuba's all Cuban and
a couple black guys man and you has my
wrestling team you're white and you grow
up
oh yeah me you have to work a little bit
of harder yeah I remember when I went to
Miami my cousin was friends with a white
guy yeah that was just tough because he
had to be yeah
like he had no choice never forget I was
being like 16 skateboarded me being a
New Yorker going he [ __ ] nuts because
and I realized I got white kids in Miami
got a double-up it's like white dad of
Miami yeah I got a suck good dick is the
competition level is high if you're a
white chick in Miami and you ain't givin
up titties dichotic ha ha ok will suck
your dick in eighth grade you know the
same showing you're a white chick in
Miami you gotta work double hard ain't
nobody gonna dance with your dog ain't
nobody gonna [ __ ] prom because those
little Cuban refugee chicks and let
their grandfather in Cuba they die in
the second day nor the movie theater
with Grandma and my day you had a
[ __ ] take the grandma to the movie
theater with the chicken you know the
mother or the brother the gorilla
brother is something like these [ __ ] I
used to go to red berry baseball camp
did you ever got a red berry baseball
camp in Miami III didn't go to it but
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's like a staple
yeah it was it was part of my youth and
I really don't talk about I used to
spend my summers where did you grow up
in Miami no I grew up in Jersey
but I had a godfather who lived in the
Falls yeah helped the Falls and the
cities yeah my monkey jungle
130 at the 100 Avenue he would he was a
contractor right and he would build
neighborhoods so he would build a house
he'd move into it and then he builds
four houses that duplicated that house
and he would sell them he'd take a no
loan from the bank and he would sell so
I would spend my summers in the summers
I had to work I like that
there oh yeah get down him get bit by
red ants you don't know when life is
till you pick up a sweat
and it's filled with red ants and you're
gonna run like a girl and put hot water
on you or whatever they did and then the
red ants off your Miami was a complete
yeah I was a city kid
yeah my cousin oh I hope I'm asking if
you're from Miami you're honest man you
from you Bri from New Jersey
yes from Cuba but then Jersey Grammar
School in high school yeah man
you know man I I spent some time up in
Jersey man Jersey's cool man my my mom
used to run the racetrack in Atlantic
City racetrack oh yeah in Atlantic City
man and uh and she's uh yes she's so
she's spent her summers up there and
then she'd come down you should come
down to Florida now for the wintertime
she runs in the restaurants of the
racetrack like Gulf Stream and then
Monmouth Park and I love Jersey mint
Mama's Park that's a good race yeah
that's a Jersey Girls - man like Jersey
gross oh hell yeah man they're cool man
it's it's gee I love Jersey man that's
crazy I love it - I have no problems in
Jersey I think it's like anywhere else
now it's overcrowded the traffic you
know what Jersey has some beautiful
parts I will never be ashamed of growing
up or I did I think it made me who the
[ __ ] I am it really did I really enjoyed
coming up to County I really did till
today I get little [ __ ] notes on
Twitter from people and shifting lunch
in town I love it
I fought in Newark New Jersey my six pro
fight was in Newark New Jersey at the
Robert Reid hotel and and this guy this
guy knocked me down twice in the second
round and then I came back and knocked
him on the third round but it was uh it
was um that was one of those moments
where like I was like you know what I
don't know if I need a box
this is just it's too much man and and
and and so then I I went to the dressing
room and I was buttoning up my pants and
all the sudden I was like maybe what
just what just happened I had a like a
moment where
like you know like after a heavy night
of drinking and you don't really
remember like you know you know what you
did the night before all of a sudden
then my corner man
Charlie King was he goes he's like we
tell him I'm like Charlie just tell me
what just happened then he like as he
started telling me it all came back to
me and that's when I was new I knew did
I have a concussion and so it's like I
probably had plenty of concussions man
and uh yeah dude if that's why I got out
of the sport of boxing man how long is a
transition between boxing and acting did
you go to an acting class right away did
you go to an acting school did you move
out here yeah I went to New York for a
little while I was working at the China
Club I was bouncing there man and for
about six months man guys like Jimmy
vanetti and I did Kirk McLane these guys
were just legendary guys that ran and
ran in you know the security at all
these clubs man and it was just it was
just it was a fun time what years were
you this was this was October 2002 to
January 2001
no no knocked over I'm sorry August so
it was like six months or six months I
was there man and so it was just man it
was just it was incredible man and did
you take acting classes in New York yeah
it was uh yeah it was great man
it was uh I took some acting classes
there but I was you know I was having no
luck and I ran into Michael Rapaport at
the China Club you know Michael Rapaport
blow the podcast yeah Judy I'm the
biggest fan a nice guy you see he comes
he's there and I and I walked up to him
when I go ahead man I go uh you're uh
you made it as an actor like did you
make it here in New York or did you make
it in LA and he goes do you want to do
film and television I was like yeah he
goes you need to move to LA and then I
was like all right a couple weeks later
packed up my my truck and made it I'll
tell them what year was this this is
January 2001 and uh and so then I came
out of here man with a bunch of group of
actors we started doing casting director
workshops and stuff like that and
I was mad I didn't know my ass from my
elbow man I really didn't
what kind of casting directors were you
meeting with the time you remember Oh
God aye aye aye
I think Marnie sayyida was one of them
because I got a part I got a part you
know I got it like an under-five who's
my first my first role and so I'm trying
to remember some of the others I can't I
can't remember
so I actually met with my agent he
turned me down and then he didn't he
sign me 10 years later he signed me 10
years later so it was I was very green
man it was it was like a green it was
like no I know she'd listen I got what I
want yeah no [ __ ] man I moved here I was
in Seattle some guy comes up to me after
a show he was you're perfect for a pilot
I am shooting I swear to God sure right
I'm a [ __ ] I'm out on bail I'm living
with a stripper I'm [ __ ] basically
yeah I mean I didn't know what I was
gonna do I mean I didn't know what I was
on the dope and there was December of 96
hmm it was Thanksgiving of 96 that was
the weekend he went to visit his family
and he just had that was the second year
in a row somebody approached me over the
Thanksgiving weekend that was from a
lady that was visiting family up there
and saw me hmm so the second time he
came up to me this guy he's like you
know you want to do this pilot let me
look into it give me your contact info
and I I don't know what the thing I got
it know what to think like hey man what
are you selling bra because it's a CBS
pilot and it's uh you'd be playing the
Spanish bartender that you know whatever
I remember a Spanish bartender where
they come through information to like a
Snuggie bet atomic type of guy very
serious and they always have to work me
over for information come on Joey you
know the information that type of [ __ ]
and it was called Bronx County but they
were looking that was perfect and they
called and they called again
and then I got a probation violation and
they wanted to throw me in jail so I
told the guy from the CVS he goes let me
[ __ ] make some calls and they called
the [ __ ] judge and wrote a letter he
was crazy dude man they [ __ ] got out
uh see how they the guys like don't come
back and I came down and they wanted me
to go to counseling classes for assault
and I never went to the classes so they
but I kept down here and I [ __ ] up so
bad on that pilot that I was like that's
this is never gonna happen again what a
shame
oh yeah like what a shame what an
embarrassment I am that I didn't know
about acting classes hmm I got before we
started the podcast we're watching the
Steven Seagal movies and lethal weapon I
still remember watch his blind date oh
my god with Bruce Willis man with some
cat eyes and telling my roommate what
are you gonna call your camera buddy and
tell him about me like I thought you
just made calls oh yeah like I just
don't like it like my friend told me one
time like I have a friend that works at
hammers in a lie yeah he shot this movie
I didn't leave that guy alone for three
years when he would call your buddy
talking about me I'm a [ __ ] Savage
that's like sometimes you'll be talking
to like an aunt or somebody and and
they're like hey so um you know we were
we were watching that CSI the other
night and you know who we thought would
be good on there Shawn would be good on
that can you why don't you call them why
don't you tell them yeah just call
somebody I love when people say that it
doesn't work right so I didn't know I
wish it worked like that I didn't know
what was going on Shawn Geary I'm like I
have a right don't carry it and I
watched a thousand movies and I had no
idea about nothing and then I sign with
this manager now and he's like yeah
stand-up is great but you're gonna have
to go on auditions on me are you talking
about that's never gonna happen
I'm calling my dishes and he shot me
around that and I came down two to eight
he sent me had pictures to like 35
agents and I was turned that by thirty
three of them and only two aides inside
me this dude that's still around yeah
I'm gonna say his name he's still a bum
he's still a bum man they still he
wanted money to send that you have elope
stash it was time to be oh yeah yeah you
have to pay me a hundred a month for
postage and handling until you book
something the [ __ ] Hattie and these two
beautiful black girls called the
coloring book Wow and you had to send
that whole yeah headshots with different
color paper but they were called the
coloring book for a reason they
specialize with kids and characters but
she had me out
two days later like she was sending me
out two days all the time and I'm not
shown carrying it I'm going in there
what does that mean man nah I'm going in
there
not even close no like just shaking them
telling me thank you for coming in like
thank you for coming in and then finally
I said okay but I think I gotta take it
an acting class and I took an acting
class they taught me the basics of scene
study for a high-ranked magnet and then
I said [ __ ] this and the biggest class
in town was uh not Leslie Kahn but the
other Yvonne Yvonne
Monica each other yeah I went to Ravana
Chubut oh that's crap man that guy
really broke it down for me but while I
was going to his class I was booking now
my god I had booked when I booked
basketball I didn't even know what the
line was I didn't know what action cut
my god I was coked up the night before I
slept I was the first scene up huh if I
still remember them going right I know
on your marks I could bend over the race
[Music]
there was no right cool oh I couldn't
roller skate when I was supposed to roll
this game basketball when I go away I'm
there I'll row this case I just may
believe thankful like people are hiring
me and just hating on me
hating me you understand what that's
like and people at home never had that
idea like hating me and once I went to
acting class I got a little bit more and
then I took a cold reading work yeah do
you think you think maybe you started
respecting the craft more when she
started studying it they informed me of
what was happening uh what was happening
I didn't know what was happening I don't
have any [ __ ] idea and you sending me
scripts and I'm going at the read what
[ __ ] the act is moving my hand is
shaking I have no idea people think that
you just step on a lot no I can shake
your maracas this all these levels of
the table man it's just it's just in but
my wife got me a workshop cold reading
workshop with the guy who cast Godfather
to Donnie Brasco and a bunch of stuff
sleepers hmm and he brought in this
really helped me he brought in the
audition tapes from sleepers oh that's
it made us look through all the audition
tapes of the people that are auditioned
mm-hm and why we would pick those people
and a game oh wow that's cool man and
that helped me yeah I took that class
that was 2001 at UCLA hmm guess who I
sat next to Bryan Callen is that right
man I Love New York Rogan and Wow
he was the class talking to chicks you
know the whole thing that's it over here
which me and him was surrounded by 92
[ __ ] women and that helped me and I
did the Christian Kaplan workshop
Connolly put me in the movie taxi yeah
two weeks later he called me who's
coming audition for this they had given
it to Bobby Slayton already but he liked
me better and he gave it to me and Bobby
till this day would say [ __ ]
he's still [ __ ] taxi from me but it
took me three years to really get my
acting chops up yeah but still man you
did it you know you I'm gonna take you
to really get your acting chops up well
what happened to me is I fell on my I
fell on the goddamn face man like I'd
I did a movie it was so bad they said
they said Sean Kerrigan has a better
chance of modeling leather jackets than
ever being an actor that was a review
some cold-blooded [ __ ] man was
cold-blooded and so that's why like I
was like I was like man I kind of like I
just wasn't ready I did I did a I did a
TV show called next action star back in
2004 and it was thought it was gonna be
like the next American Idol for actors
and so they auditioned people all over
the country and they got to they got to
LA and they see and they select 14 girls
14 guys and then you have screen tests
each week you know and they eliminate
more people eliminated people eliminate
people until finally the people winners
of each screen test for each week for
ten ten weeks that person gets to star
in his own action film the guy in the
girl who win it and so me and a girl
named Corinne van Richter group it's a
mouthful we run it and we we want it and
then and then we got the star in our own
TV movie out in Cleveland and we went
and we shot it and I had it I had to
take a fake name because the show hadn't
come out yet
and NBC thought it was gonna be huge so
like I was walk I had a alias Sonny
Briggs or Sonny Hopkins and then my
character name was Sonny Briggs and the
movie just sucked it just they think
they called it bet your life they should
have called it bet your career who
directed it I mean that they do it like
a right job everywhere you know man
wrote it and it look I don't wanna I
don't want to you know dog any anybody
that helped make it because I think that
what they were working with was an actor
I wasn't ready to store and I wasn't
ready to star in an action my own action
film I wasn't ready to carry a film you
know you got to understand like you're
gonna get like rewrites sometimes or
like it's raining outside tomorrow so
now we can't we can't shoot the exterior
we're gonna shoot this interior on page
60 to learn you know you got those 10
pages right like
you have to like it's just I wasn't
ready I wasn't ready for that level and
uh and you know so then I just I you
know I I didn't work for a little while
and TV and film probably about six years
it was you know I didn't book a TV or
film job in six years and and then I
just said [ __ ] this man I'm not gonna am
I gonna go out like this so I started
studying at Playhouse West I started
just learn the craft of acting I went
back in the beginning beginning in class
worked my way up to the advanced wente
little program
it's Meisner and and and so I did that
and then and then I just started doing
stand-up I was like I gotta like I got
to be able to make fun of this this
situation or I'm like you know I'm not
gonna get working again and then next
thing you know man I started working I
started working as soon as I started
doing stand-up comedy I started working
the auditions a lot yeah man I you know
I just I think it just helped with a lot
of things man it was like just it helped
me helped me like talk about like I had
a chip on my shoulder man for a long
time you know I was like this you know
ex-pro box for me and Jon Bernthal would
go out and we get in all kinds of bar
fights and [ __ ] all the time it's just
like it was just a very weird life man
was in it was a very like it just just
want a little bit of a frustration yeah
it's like when you shoulder yeah man you
know when things don't go your way for a
while yeah you become this a phase that
you go yeah man it's a certain age yeah
and a and I had failed at the movie that
I this was my shot man my one shot you
know they said that cuz they said this
show was gonna be like the next American
Idol and it just bombed it just was
terrible and the network was it uh it
was on NBC man it was on NBC and and
they thought it was gonna be what
happened was they shot it like the real
world they didn't shoot it they didn't
shoot it like what people wanted to see
which was the acting train the acting
classes we took with Howard fine the
stunt training I would find on Fairfax
yeah dude Howard fine was our acting
coach
yeah the old guy yeah yeah
the student the studio Howard fine
studio and so I think that is is I think
he's on Fairfax now I'm not sure he's
not good yeah he was on Melrose at some
point and and that's when we like trying
but he's a vet he's a like fantastic
acting teacher but but sooo that's what
they didn't see get all that [ __ ] they
saw like people like arguing over like
[ __ ] like real world yeah people
were like I thought we were gonna see
the like next edition next action star
like were like all the stunts training
and all the the acting classes and all
this which all these all stuff we did
but they just what was the first place
you got on stage and God what's the name
of that that place in North Hollywood
man - ha ha no no no no it's a
restaurant that used to have a lemon
o'clock open mic good time the restroom
no no no man I can't I can't remember
the name right now liquid liquid liquid
zoo in liquid zoo in van nuys that was
it man like we do and I told just
terrible by yourself no my ex-wife wound
with me and so and so she saw it it was
just terrible it was just awful what
made you go back the second time cuz I
got a couple laughs on some gross [ __ ]
that I said and uh and then I just I
just you know I just I just I know no
man I just I read Steve Martin's book it
said born standing up there called good
book good and he talked about how like
how many times he bombed and I was like
[ __ ] man you know like I used to get my
[ __ ] ass kicked in boxing but I say
but but I got through it it's all I got
I got through the times you and I sucked
you know I got through it and and so now
it's like alright well I'm gonna get you
know you just get to worry you know
you're just gonna hope I hope to get
better so it's so weird now when you
just work at it is when you're an actor
yeah and you add stand up to your
repertoire even if you don't do it
officially you do it as an exercise MA
like I saw Emilio Rivera from Sons of
Anarchy hmm I met him 20 years ago and
he was acting but he said that something
about stand-up helped him audition now
and years later as an audition after I
had auditioned a hundred times and
sucked dick on all of them I learned how
to take the mitzi concept when you
showcase for me you got three minutes
all right when I call you up and I go
I'm putting your life's hands on three
minutes you never hang up the phone and
go what the [ __ ] do I do in three
[ __ ] minutes well it's the same
amount of time when you go into an
audition yeah yeah sure man I've got
three minutes so you got three minutes
to make them to love you fall in love
with you so I started taking that
concept of stand-up and Brent like I
went in for [ __ ] movies that you
would die after I did I think by 2000 I
got rid of the manager and the coloring
book disbanded by themselves the one
chick's husband cheated on a white chick
you don't do that to a sister they just
fell apart at the scene huh and I signed
with the guy with his the weirdest story
in the world the manager I was with was
a badass [ __ ] hmm he had grown
up in Beverly Hills with the belly Hills
high went to Syracuse with the whole
crew and knew everybody and I'll never
forget that we were all sitting there
when we walk around a meeting with then
he goes listen I gotta get you an agent
I can't keep sending you out like this
rogue in those days managers weren't
supposed to send ya and really in 97-98
no oh wow managers were not supposed to
send you up Jewish managers didn't give
a [ __ ] they were trying to get the
lights paid so I didn't give a [ __ ]
Jeff was that manager but Jeff wasn't
getting me out for co-stars Jeff was
giving me 9 page
you said ypd bleuleads yeah and I'm
going in then it's Danny Trejo and
another Mexican from [ __ ] missed it
and I'm like you know the first 10
auditions I went and I lost in the room
just humming my name when I turn around
that's the guy from Goodfellas in the
freezer yeah you know right there that's
that guy that's this guy that's that guy
I was nosy
that's the auditions he had me gone in
into the beginning so how did you
finally get over all stand up I did a
story tellers show on the belly room one
night and it came to me well that when I
go in for an audition I'm telling the
story it's not just ah how are you good
to see slate my name's Joey Diaz okay
let's read those two lines one of the
first auditions I figured it out was the
James Coburn one I figured out that it's
not just one line it's a wine on paper
that doesn't mean I'm gonna turn I have
my job to turn that one line into three
yeah and that's what I would do I would
give them a beginning a middle an ending
just like a stand-up set so no matter
what that thing was I did it opposite I
always wanted the same Wow I always had
the last line I don't give a [ __ ] what
you wrote [ __ ] correct me in the room
but when I walked in there I bulldogged
yeah I learned how I blogged the casting
Wow
and guess who I read that from a picture
by the name of the rocket Oh Louie Tiant
no the other [ __ ] lunatic from Boston
Red Sox that ended up in a Houston that
was Apollo II uh he was a Clemens
Clemens Roger Corman logic if you ever
watch a Roger Clemens pitch what do you
mean he's a bully he was a big time Oh
is he oh but you didn't see it on TV oh
wow I'm saw it live no [ __ ] you saw it
live he beat you without throwing a
pitch wow man
so now that's what you have to start
doing when you go into an audition you
have to beat them without saying like
one time I walk them to you if you see
it today every once in a while people go
Joey I just saw it on
a thing were you an extra on that what's
that job Oh how I Met Your Mother
that over two and a Half Men gonna have
Men Two and a Half Men too huh but how I
Met Your Mother I went in there my pants
ripped I had no underwear and I asked
the castevets if she saw the Kuban I
grow and they just died and I'll never
forget like they were dying so hard that
I walked out and my agent calling let's
go back and read yeah and then they put
me on the set and I was the wrong dude
right but I got to that level by
starting to book one-liners mmm one
liners like turned into [ __ ] three
yeah like I became the [ __ ] Captain
Kirk of the enterprise let them tell me
to read it how its read read it how it's
written okay
but I already got you it's too late it's
like when you go to court and you just
go you know that Lee raped the chick one
time that's irrelevant scratch that from
the jurors the jurors please disregard
that comment it's too late you made the
kind yeah you already hit out of the
park [ __ ] yeah so I would make sure on
the first read I hit it out of the park
my stop ba-ba-ba-ba
I remember going on ABC pilot one time
when I went ahead it was about a guy who
was white trash hmm who was [ __ ] poor
in the neighborhood and he was war here
like that Wow Kmart swimming pool and he
was watering it like which slippers are
on and whatever in his mind he came from
the ghetto this was like big-time living
here
Porto Rican barbecue little hibachis man
and he had a three hot dogs on there and
he was this guy he felt that he was a
big shot
I [ __ ] put tighty-whities on I wait
380 now I like this and sweatpants when
I walked in my plan was to walk in and
pull my pants down and have the tighty
whities and blow my little water
oh no that's how you audition right yeah
your audition to be remember look the
part you auditioned to be what you learn
that from Milton's Milton could sell us
no yes that's how you learn that
yeah and I loved it from Milton
casella's and yeah didn't die from the
Godfather - yeah you don't audition to
book the role huh you audition to be
remembered yeah so I walked in the room
and delays were great that you made it
can you give us one minute to confer
when they turn around I dropped those
sweatpants and I took this leg out and
Here I am I took my sneakers off and
everything with my big Fred Flintstone
feet
I got a Patti wide yeah I took my shirt
off and I had a gut and tits and I may
believe I was watering the thing and I
go look at me and they both all three of
them turned around at once and I go
living like a [ __ ] doctor done and
the class they said put that on the tape
they died right there they go just put
that you put the camera say that one
more time just like that without the
[ __ ] and I'm where they oh look at me
living like a doctor ha ha ha ha ha
I walk down that kind of told everybody
gone like go home the same for you you
know saying go home the same for you
yeah I did I think what's clear like
yeah but by the time I walk to the car
yeah yeah by the time I get to the car
we get the call because I would I didn't
go in there once I get out you don't go
in there to book the roll it's just like
stand-up comedy what happened to me the
last six months I was doing stand-up to
please the audience you know what since
when am I [ __ ] you're all a monkey
that's gonna play a drum I'm there to do
what I do and whether you like it that's
your problem that's the problem with
stand-up now they're flipping it on you
we're starting to believe that I started
to believe that I started stand-up to
make you feel uncomfortable and to make
you think and to let you know that what
I'm telling you is the truth
I'm paying on it right those people in
Thailand that thing that happened in
Thailand using the [ __ ] those kids to
the cave I'm telling you I don't give a
[ __ ] what you think that it was a
Christian is right enough it's been
raining out of line you don't see me
going it okay with 12 other
[ __ ] he was gonna [ __ ] those
little jab kids there's no two ways
about it and I don't letting everybody
know I don't know for what they tell you
nobody's gonna tell you that coach was
saying that's his jr. he was studying
the readings of Sandusky and [ __ ]
send us he read a book in prison
as little boys cheering this
[ __ ] took him 2.0 and then take
him to the basement he took them to the
[ __ ] cave he said to the basement
[ __ ] in the ass let you go home with a
balloon [ __ ] you to death and I'm
leaving here for the crocodiles but they
[ __ ] up with the bicycles nobody
believes me yeah
nobody believes me that's what really
happened and that's what you have said
about the bicycle when they leave they
like I don't know Joey you had a point
about that [ __ ] why would he take him to
a cave so what it was raining you stand
up door under a tree huh it's [ __ ] up
what stand up is now you want you guys
like Kennison it dice that we're really
pushing the envelope and you're like
that's what I have to be doing you know
it doesn't work for everybody I mean I
also meant like yeah man it's also like
it's what your wit your flavor of comedy
is man you know what I mean like like
like I love I like that's what I love
people to push the [ __ ] Ambu after
ain't got time I'm 50 I'm an dilly-dally
I don't give a [ __ ] about Netflix HBO
Showtime I'm looking to rip that [ __ ]
stage apart now I'm looking to leave
smoke up there and I wanna well I step
off that I want the battlefield to look
like [ __ ] like I shot everybody like
like Vegas like a battlefield like
that's what you're supposed to leave
them like people Blaine all over the
place bleeding that's what comedy is
yeah bombarding the [ __ ] audience and
I lost that I lost that and it's the
same thing when you go into an audition
you know I still remember a bow I know
what I would say to you so I got this
guy Jeff Gavin he's got connections that
[ __ ] CAA he's got connections
everywhere but he goes don't there's an
H I want you to me you know I don't like
her but we're gonna take a meeting
anyway because she's the best agent for
you right and at that time if you want a
pilant in the middle there where there's
a parking lot it used to be an old still
then like you were scared when you park
to the underground you were really
scared like the underground parking
there you like I don't know if I'm gonna
make I used to sell porn across the
street from there
when I first got here there was a job
telemarketing you saw a point eight
bucks now and you will in then just
called [ __ ] places and said I have to
lay this Lucy Lou take it up the ass huh
and they would order I quit after a week
it was it for me I stole his soul cigars
but it was just a shitty name but
Highland and then Hollywood yeah Emma
lies man above above [ __ ] Hollywood
Boulevard after nine o'clock at night
you better bring a weapon Jack walking
into the 101 there right there that used
to be bad news really bad that corner
there with the subway and everything
like there that turns into Franklin yeah
they used to be an island with a
building so I asked him where to meet
him and he tells me meet me at that
Island and I go you want me to meet you
for the [ __ ] agent that's where their
office is like nobody's officers on
[ __ ]
some people's offices were on the lot
you want me to go you're telling me that
the agent you want me to go meet and it
was Daniel off agency no [ __ ] and they
won the fourth floor of the scary when
you press the elevator they on the way
that took forever this is no this is
this is this has to be 1999-2000 no
should I met her a week before Christmas
and the name was Nancy act
she was from Chicago and the insight was
on the street the word on the street was
yeah you could go to this agency and
that agency but if you really want to
work just lady don't [ __ ] stop and I
don't mean she was like that but she was
that lady without the cigarette mm-hmm
help you today
okay [ __ ] headshots all over a desk
in a gin martini Danny this is the back
side get with commercials I was a Sutton
Bart Ehrman re Danny was in the back
doing commercials there was a three-man
operation that's crazy
operation that's crazy man so she came
out Danny came and said I don't need you
for commercial I'm with Sutton Bart
Ehrman are we cool yeah and then she
goes I want to sign you I go let me talk
to my manager we left that building
you're [ __ ] kidding me yeah dawg
if you wanna go out that's the lady I
still am mind with me and there was the
truth you know I found one of those
about two years ago that's when I was
going on three TV shows per week mm-hmm
and two feature films and I'm talking
about name it
I could read damn she was getting you
out like that huh like that Wow
this has to be 2002-2003 before the
computer no you do it hand submit oh
it's a different time and there's some
Thomas guides and Sheila's go ahead yet
have a Thomas guide to get another have
a headshot
you better have a headshot on it I show
up without a headshot you had a search
on every two weeks and at 49 that's done
they would call you yeah we need more
yeah but you as an agent as a client I
would show up every week I would
Walternate headshots mm-hmm every week
every Sunday I would staple 50 map yeah
you gotta cut the sheets eight my exact
cuz that's yeah headshot to do it all
man yeah I'm [ __ ] kidding it was work
jack you didn't just [ __ ] act yeah
you had a staple them perfectly I'd
always go to kink or Kinkos FedEx and
use the slider the slicer resumes well
they used to be a FedEx right on son
said that first it was mr. Chow mr. Chow
was across from the Guitar Center so he
did all my resumes he was slicing for me
and I would staple them mr. Chow is
printing well I lived in there the
headshots with La Brea and sunset behind
hoyes walk that was the headshot place
you were in there every three weeks I
had the $79 did you was Ray the
retouchers around then ray the return
was there so people go retouched this
right nothing's gonna save this face
forget gray the retoucher that was a big
thing back then we loved your headshots
but you have a little blemish on your
head yeah well that gives me character
right I'm not giving ray the retouch 80
bucks to retouch and then you look like
you died they put that [ __ ] a funeral
makeup on you and your headshot but the
[ __ ] ray to retouch it
I was brutal with those people brutal I
used to tell them you use the headshots
I got and then once should we book a job
done I get mad shot because it always
give you a list
sure have to take a picture with thing
you call the guy 300 hours enough I got
a Puerto Rican with a camera that's the
$29 he does [ __ ] 100 headshots
he poses even lets me shoot him at the
end you know I'm saying what do the you
you're a carpenter
there was agents that would say you got
to come back with a picture of Glee as a
baker
she let me draw a picture you're
throwing a pizza up in the air come on
land in 97 when you went listen dog they
had first of all every year they have a
new scam then you have to sign up for
sure to help you expedite your career it
costs you 69.95 a years something
there's always something and then in
those days it was cast net Oh cast net
yeah it was uh it was cast net I mean to
become an actor in those days it cost
you a lot of money yeah because you had
to get the right headshots and they
wanted a headshot for each thing they
saw you at so Sean Kerrigan came to me
he would be the Irish priest I want a
headshot as you as a priest I want a
headshot as you as a construction guy I
want a headshot as you as a boxer yeah
so they wanted all these headshots are
you crazy
people gone broke in this town they
wanted four hundred four four poses of
you like you know what a kid to would
and wouldn't wait all these people that
had all these places do man where did
they go like how like you know cuz it's
like you you're thinking yourself you're
like these guys I mean who are they all
doing digital now is that what's
happening everything is big they had to
like lost all their all their [ __ ]
okay across the street from Ralph's is a
Chinese restaurant there's a Russian
market and down the block that whole
corner at one time hmm what'd I tell you
that that whole corner he had ten people
behind the counter you had to pick a
number to go in that corner he was to
get headshot duplicate so you went to
LaBrea
okay so first you had to go get a
headshot Lee yeah okay huh 300 then you
had to take the sheet to your agent and
they had I'll prove it yeah yeah they
wanted so they want out of the 36
pictures they want 22 at $5 apiece right
to put into like postcards and they put
into post costs then you got to bring
lack this was the process now then you
have to bring them back they spread them
on the table in the table and then again
they go I give me that and that one that
one that's another 22 a piece yeah and
you got to come back the next day with
those three and then they go okay go get
me a hundred of these 100 of these at
$79.99 five a piece so you went down
there you wanted your [ __ ] you
ordered your [ __ ] tank and then from
there after you picked up the hundred
headshots no no after you picked up the
regular shots yeah you took them to the
corner of I don't know the street with
the one before or [ __ ] routes and
there he made you 100 copies so all this
money already then you had to get 100
copies and you had to get memory you had
I get commercial headshots and
theatrical headshots yeah that's right
you you said you had to double down this
is crazy what I did yeah I used to tell
him after a year I told him to suck my
dick I don't give a [ __ ] send that
[ __ ] headshot send that out I don't
give a [ __ ] what it looks like yeah then
they all want the real yeah I still
remember being shooting analyze that and
it was such a great scene with me and
Anthony them partly in the beginning
that I tried to get the scene the movie
wasn't getting released till December so
you tried to get the scene before the
movie came out yeah and they wouldn't
give him they wouldn't give it they
wouldn't give it I got a call one day
from a friend of money because you want
you saying I got it
what cuz I got you seen come over to my
house so I went to his house and he had
the scene but it was backwards because
when you steal it off the computer
it comes back backwards that's trying to
take the scene to these guys come on man
you found guys to fix this dog these
people Rob Parham on there's people on a
daily basis man that's a business yeah
yeah that's a business yeah absolutely
oh yeah they stole the prelims and they
release them all those Africans in New
York that sell you the movies yes some
of them citizen movie theater and tape
but there's some guys on the up-and-up
sure they know something they pay ten
thousand and then they make ten thousand
copies they sell them for $5 apiece mwah
it's $50,000
without nonprofit and those movies go
from computer to computer so these guys
would steal off the computers this guy
call me one I didn't ask him to do that
he was his guy he was like an army guy
and I was steal like the army taught him
how to steal yeah he was I got you seen
but you have to flip it so instead of me
being in the movie I was on the left
hand side now I was in the right hand
side it was a nightmare and I took it to
these guys I'm Mel right now I gotta
bring in the backpack yeah like that's
what these guys did sure they they had
to vault back there and they flipped it
then they gave it to me but then I
listen if you send it up you and
paramount sees it you're gonna go to
jail
well he said that big homie just wait
for three months yeah you know there was
just so many obstacles oh wait a second
so you didn't send it out no I threw it
away I was like only one in my house oh
yeah a long way to December I ain't
gonna change my life that much in my
mind did they tell you that after you
paid them what do you mean like Dom tell
me before they went out work and nobody
asked me for money like this was long on
the up-and-up
mom this is way before the pockets this
wasn't just a guy was complained to but
one night about the scene he's like let
me talk to some guy and next thing I
know he's like this guy wants to talk to
you got the same for you yeah you know
it's weird man
you don't think about how much piracy
there is out there man but it's like
people like man it's dude it's like you
think about that man it's like people I
got a buddy of mine who say hey man uh
when she come over and watch his movie
I'm like that movies out in the theaters
he's like yeah no no I got it I'm like
how are you he always has I'm like I'm
like man you guys stop stealing all
these movies man you think he stole them
no sorry he knows it at them yeah that
gives you those previews yeah man and
they say [ __ ] on them yeah they'll say
[ __ ] on them that you're not supposed to
see like they'll keep coming up saying
property of alright well now they have
boxes and it's because it's all online
they have boxes they sell on Amazon that
you can buy that you get everything you
all free TV free sports free
pay-per-views yeah they call it's called
Cody I mean they're good the
they shut it down every once in a while
but they just build it back up so how
long did it take you
hmm to act full-time as a full-time like
right now you're a how long have you
been a fool my back you just paying the
bills with acting for probably about 12
years really full right maybe 10 years
10 10 years yeah make you know not be 12
probably 12 maybe yeah I mean sometimes
better than others you know but I
started working I started working again
in in commercials commercials and so you
know I booked a couple commercials from
front like I booked that Geico
commercial you know the one where he
goes through the airport yeah and then
the guy on the sign is me and so I made
just you know I paid the bills with that
you know all year pretty much and so I
would I would little like commercials
here and there and you know make it you
know I've shot a lot of commercials so
so then I started I started doing
stand-up and once I started doing
stand-up then it's just like I started
working in TV and film and and and that
was about does yeah
you own a soap opera for a while I was
on the soap opera I was on The Young and
the Restless three and a half years
Christ yeah
started out four episodes and then I
told him I said you know yeah you know I
just I just did I did the best I did I I
told myself that this is an opportunity
for these people to bring you back so
just try to make something out of these
four episodes and make them want to keep
seeing you man and also were you acting
before you got these four episodes oh
this happened it I was like oh no I
guess I've been acting about 12 12 years
yeah yeah yeah 12 years how was the
transition I think that was one up for
me mm-hmm I was you know I felt a long
as yard my confidence was up what acting
right the 17 weeks of work yeah all
those people you grow a level now I grew
a level from the auditions I got tough
the longest shot groovy level
you know the directors you work with me
you learn as you go man you learn as
you've never prepared no no come one day
this is what happened I did that you
know that she's a good Giulini
what's her name Carla Giulini she had a
TV show for a while on ABC she did the
movie American Gangster she played the
leads wife of carla Gugino round for a
long time
check out American Gangster what Denzel
yeah who played a the white guy his wife
she had a TV show yeah and it taped it
at the strip club on Lancashire that
episode that play the bouncer how was a
Daniel huh for a couple years
yeah man then Nancy left Wow Nancy
flipped and left huh and in those days
you know I was doing coke and I know I
knew the timing scheduling checks you
done TV show dirty you know they always
tell you TV 10 days movies or
commercials 30 days what's it in college
you Judy no GU GI get take two waters so
I was with Daniel often great guys
nothing I'm not saying anything bad
about him but they check process was a
little slow for me yeah they would take
too long to pay me and hold the checks I
don't have time for that [ __ ] oh yeah I
know your commission I'd pay admission
when you got my money don't [ __ ] around
my money well they're great now man no
three hours a day
yeah and your agent that was great it
was funny huh I had to call him one
thing though where's my money and
they're like we sent it I don't know you
didn't there we never get then they call
back I said we never got to check his
own production company said we'll send
it at 3 so I called Danny I go listen if
you don't have my money I'm going over
there if you don't have my money you're
going off the [ __ ] window then when I
got over there there was a check on the
door with my paperwork all my headshots
and stuff we don't want to represent you
know more the door was blocked a check
yeah whoa and then do you know that get
the hell out yeah that was probably
right before cuz they got me spider-man
2
they got me a bunch of [ __ ] I was loved
for four years yeah I left him right
before maybe the longest yard and then
maybe like in 2012 I had to take my cat
to the vet and the earth there was Danny
no [ __ ]
because I hate don't know how he's doing
Danny I [ __ ] up that day I'm sorry he
goes odd things happen he goes who you
with I go put some pieces hey just gonna
be called later come back that was it I
was like three years oh man that's cool
that good people Dave my guy is now New
York now right Dave is in New York and
then you have the really good black dude
you have a tournament having Turner
Kevin Turner the most monotone human
you'll ever meet yeah he was I know a
motion yeah dude he's a machine he's
actually he's a computer yeah it's like
my first meeting with him I was like man
that [ __ ] went terrible man he just like
shows no it's like a poker face when you
come from before you sign with Daniel I
dunno I just had a manager I know agent
I did a workshop at an agent workshop
and I told you I wasn't working in TV
and film for like six years so I started
taking these these casting director
workshops and and I took an agent
workshop and next thing you know he was
there you saw me do a monologue called
me in his office then like just like who
he is his like shows no emotion no
motion I was like well well that's
that's done and the next thing you know
and call me back probably in again and
saw me so and the rest has been history
man now I just you know I I just tease
him about how awkward he is all the time
dude man happy you got to get out of the
show and talk a little bit I got one of
those guys in LA every time I see you
put a smile on my face because there's
no bullshitting you know like thanks man
you're very yeah and you travel a lot
doing stand-up good you know a good
amount I mean I'm not really getting out
on the road too much right now I I'm on
I'm on at the ha tonight I'm sorry I'm
month ahaha Friday night and Saturday
and I'm Friday on the 11 o'clock show
and then Saturday on the 8:30 8:45 show
so but not like I get out like
I get out a little bit I've done Canada
a couple times I had lined up at Yuk
Yuk's in Toronto they uh so I did that
for a weekend and then I did I did the
Yuk Yuk's up in Vancouver and so like
I'll do like you know I get out a little
bit i headline in montana and did a you
know weekend in montana so always a
little tough you know man it's just it's
tough yeah and i have to break into this
stand-up is tougher than it's ever been
yeah right now in LA yeah people have no
idea how hard it is to move vertically
yeah well you know I'm I think I'm lucky
in the fact that you know the haha
comedy club man they they take good care
of me man they they you know they give
me tons of spots and and they've really
shown me some love over there and so
that you know I thought grown a lot
because of that Club you know and uh not
an easy slow yeah no it's not and and
and then you know getting spots at the
Comedy Store occasionally now you know
and so you know there show me a little
bit of love so we'll see what's up man
you know positive attitude you know
you're always smiling there's never a
man that's worried out of it like I said
every time I see you I kind of giggle
because you just have a very gymnastic
voix added to it that's really well you
know I I've been taking my daughter to
this place they do the little dragon
just like from fall if I ever know the
big girls come in like I told you I
don't even I don't like this area
because the apple doesn't fall far from
the tree of the parents are a bunch of
fake [ __ ] all the kids gonna be like
I'm sure at me yesterday watching this
[ __ ] martial arts class and this girl
comes in and the other girl stops oh
she's doing him looks at her she knows
I've missed you so much
it was right out of a [ __ ] coffee
shop I know this is why I don't want to
raise my daughter here because this you
know the apple doesn't fall far from the
tree the parents are [ __ ] fake [ __ ]
I can't imagine what the kids are like
but it's guys like you there's a couple
of us in this town that still remain
true to who we are we don't give a [ __ ]
about premiers I don't give a [ __ ] about
parties I don't give a [ __ ] who's in the
room you did suck my dick oh I give a
[ __ ] I wipe my ass with your white
privilege and I'm saying if Leavitt
skinnin had no white privilege and the
Allman Brothers would have [ __ ] you
and white professed you think you are
the Helen white privilege whatever this
[ __ ] so this area just breeds this
fakeness and you don't have it so and
then you're in the business where you
have to have it to succeed you and John
both ears now have this very like I said
John made me feel on the scent of stars
whoa look at him good dude man
you know yeah last night listen let me
tell you man Jon Bernthal is he's one of
my best friends in the world and me and
that guy I've been through a lot of [ __ ]
together and you know like a lot of a
lot of situations man like you know all
kinds of different situations and he is
he has always just been he and he's like
that with all his friends man is just a
great dude man just on the level you
know where you stand with him he was
talking to me about comedy yeah he's
interested in comedy yeah he's very
interested in doing comedic roles I
think his agent suggested maybe you
should try comedic roles when I was
watching the Sicario and a couple weeks
ago and he was great in Sicario she
tries to [ __ ] the skinny chick and tries
to kill her and I and then nobody shot
puts his finger on his [ __ ] in the air
and licks it with all this [ __ ] though
it's a great movie yeah but I'm looking
at him love me this guy's got comedy
chops he just doesn't know it he hasn't
taken the plunge eh well he was on a
sitcom use on that show the class it was
a sitcom and and that I loved that show
but now he just gets like movies yeah
he's getting on me dude he's play you
know he's he's he's playing The Punisher
you know just one of the most badass
roles there are man I mean and he's just
killing it so he's doing he's doing all
right right now but it's you know III
just look man
this is a tough business and if you can
be cool with people along the way you
know and just just just be cool man just
be [ __ ] cool man just like just just
do your [ __ ] take care of yourself push
yourself and the ways that you need to
you know but don't be [ __ ] upset
about anything else you know just just
concentrate on your [ __ ] and be cool
with everybody that's it man is crazy
the thoughts you get when you're doing
this [ __ ] and the negativity that comes
in your mind and the people are the
negative that come in your mother
there's some people the man that don't
want to people don't see want to see
yeah and it kills them it really does
it kills him and ideally for people to
do well like I was watching Dean Del Ray
last night oh it's great man I taped it
and then I just said Who am I tape I
gotta watch it yeah I want Bert and Bert
was great yeah
Marc Maron was great yeah but Dean
brought a tear to my eye
Wow because that's one of my boys yes I
watch TV and I see you in a movie I go
yeah Jesus Christ that's one of my boys
and that's part of the success story if
you don't feel that way about the people
around you you're not gonna succeed if
you're not genuinely happy if I can't
look you in the face
mm no [ __ ] no [ __ ] not [ __ ] I wish I got
that no not [ __ ] how did he get that not
[ __ ] yeah he blows because I know it's
one step up we all get up yeah we all
get up is Donnie Brasco man we all get
up if you get up I get up Lee gets up as
economic yeah Tiffany Haddish got up
that means we all step up Ralphie died
Tiffany Haddish got up and louis c.k
jerked off yeah so we all moved up three
[ __ ] spots that's what happens you
move up and if you stay on that rotating
one have you stand that line you just
move up yeah and it's a matter of time
before you're there yeah you and that's
it man you're on Disneyland ride let's
click it click click click click
and that's all it is that's all it is
that's all it is when people understand
that you genuinely cheer for your peers
from your bottom of your
all right you will grow so [ __ ] much
you will grow so much that you know when
you see someone like Rogan who was made
stars on that podcast hmm how much has
he grown since that now because he
helped other people grow when you when
you were genuinely yeah man healthy
about your friends and I want me to do
stand-up but I wanted to do it the right
way so nobody ever takes it anything
from it right the same way like people
come to mingle whoa you got this because
I wrote no I didn't you forget that that
was me in spider-man too [ __ ] what
theme days listen you you get everything
you [ __ ] work for and you put the
work in and and and and just be [ __ ]
just be kind of people that are around
you when you're coming up because
there's an old saying in Hollywood man
you see the same people all the way up
seeing the seeing the same people go
exactly [ __ ] Ralph Kramden sat down
on the honeymooners in 1951 when they
were doing an episode about acting the
string of companies Shawn it was a
pleasure having you
yeah I didn't podcast about where can
people find you at this weekend I'll be
the haha no short Carrigan's oh sorry
yeah yeah Chuck
Sean Kerrigan calm on Instagram is the
real Sean Kerrigan and on Twitter at
Sean Kerrigan I love your brother so hey
man this has been it's been it's been
pretty cool man yeah no I get Charlie
just not the right I ain't gonna lie man
I was pretty nervous I was pretty
nervous because you know man
so no reason to be nervous killer now
you imagine going shoe he makes you
nervous don't worry buddy makes
everybody nervous
don't forget I'm gonna be in Philly at
the parks casino September 14th and the
following night at DC at the 9:30 club
with my [ __ ] Matt Voltron and I
want to thank my bookie you know ever
since I started this podcast people
wanna know advice Joey who's gonna win
who's having [ __ ] know if I knew was
gonna win you think I'd be doing this
[ __ ] podcast I'd be in Vegas picking
up envelopes and [ __ ]
getting my dick sucked by the Asian
women anyway that's just a fantasy you
gotta check out my book you
a gamble gambling starts this weekend
preseason you know when your bet none is
just as important to who you been with
that's why I tell people to bet with my
bookie
listen that's why I'm urging you to make
your way to my bookie I'm not telling
you I'm urging it you know why cuz you
win they pay it's that simple they have
an in-game live betting most rewarding
player perks in the business and for you
fantasy [ __ ] out there you can even bet
the oil over/under on how many fantasy
points a players on the score each game
how you like me now [ __ ] so join now
and my book you will match your deposit
dollar for [ __ ] dollar who does
that anymore use promo code Church CH
you are CH to activate the offer visit
my bookie online today
that's my bookie let me spell Athene
[ __ ] if you don't know grab a
pencil or crayon and why B oh okay I II
and don't forget to use promo code
Church and when you create a new account
to claim up to a thousand in free play
what that means is you play your win you
get paid [ __ ] and I want to give
a shout-out to Fuji Sports calm if
you're looking for a gig an under rash a
garment whatever the [ __ ] you looking
for Fuji sports got a feed I want to
thank Sean Kerrigan
we had to Carrigan's on the show this
week it's Irish we yeah she spells her
name wrong where the K or whatever the
[ __ ] yeah I mean I got my man the
[ __ ] find you aka the Christ killer
and your uncle Joey I love your
[ __ ] stay black have a
tremendous Labor Day and eat [ __ ] a
hot dog for me kick this mealy